hallo zusammen wir machen heute nach ich
glaube vier oder fünf Jahren noch mal
Macarons
mein altes Video ist einfach zu alt aber
ich lösche nichts ich stehe dazu auch
wenn sie unangenehm ist mir das so
anzuhören aber ich habe gedacht ein
neues Video über Macarons weil auch die
Nachfrage sehr sehr groß war und ich
starte direkt die schreibe euch wie
immer alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben
hier unten in die Infobox heute wieder
mit begleitender Musik von dem
Bauarbeitern draußen vor der Tür vorab
keine Angst vor Macke raus wenn man sich
wirklich an meine Tipps und Tricks hält
und dann die einzelnen Schritte dann
dachte auch nichts schief gehen ich habe
jetzt hier Puderzucker und gemahlen und
blanchierte Mandeln die findet ihr ganz
normal im Supermarkt in der
back-abteilung das sind die blanchierten
das heißt ohne Haut deswegen ist es auch
so hell und ihr könnt das müsst ihr aber
nicht aber je nachdem was ist ja auch
Naturprodukt und je nach Lagerung bei
euch zu Hause kann es sein dass da
vielleicht doch noch Klümpchen etc sind
wie sieben das Vergleich noch aber um
dann noch mal alles feiner zu bekommen
mixen wir das hier in so einem ganz
handelsüblichen Mixer meiner ich sag in
jedem Video dass der bald den Geist auch
gibt aber noch funktioniert da an sonst
könntet ihr auch es gibt auch dieses
Smoothie Maker aus habe ich was brauche
ich ist alles perfekt abgewogen Moment
das nehme ich mir jetzt noch hier genau
ihr könnt auch diesen Smoothie Mixer
sonst nehmen also hauptsache ihr mixt es
so ein bisschen aber wenn ihr wie gesagt
das nicht habt dann ist es auch okay das
mixt sich jetzt gleich zusammen mit dem
Puderzucker aber in zwei Schritten oder
so weil glaube ich nicht alles hier
reinpasst und dann genau wird es ganz
normal durch ein feines Sieb gegeben
[Musik]
hat übrigens nicht verzweifeln also es
gibt ja feine Liebe die extrem
feinmaschig sind und dann gibt's auch
noch mal feine Siebe die sind auch
relativ fein aber nicht so extrem und da
habe ich jetzt einfach ein größeres
genommen wo die Löcher die sind immer
noch fein ja aber die sind nicht ganz so
mini mini klein denn man muss schon
sagen dass das nee sonst gar nicht das
nee sage ich das ist der Mandelmehl dass
die Mandeln sonst gar nicht durchkommen
und was ich auch noch ans Herz legen
wollte ist das wenn ihr je nachdem was
für ein Mixer ihr habt und da jetzt
Hitze drin es gibt doch diese Mixer da
habt ihr so ein großes bauvorteil und
dann kommt es direkt da drauf und dann
ist die Klinge da und dann wird zu warm
das ist nicht so förderlich für unser
Mandelmehl weil dann ja das Öl austritt
bzw man sieht es jetzt nicht wirklich
aber es wird dann so ein bisschen
kompakter und dann könnt ihr das einfach
vermeiden indem ihr da immer so pulsiert
und
und nicht so oft und nicht so nicht so
lange Mix das hebe ich mir gleich alles
auf denn wie gesagt das ist wichtig man
kann ein zwei drei maximum Gramm noch
irgendwie verkraften aber ich will schon
jetzt nicht so viel verlieren hier
vorbei von meinen wertvollen Zutaten
weil es ist ja wichtig dass ihr das auch
gut abbiegt und und alles einhaltet
damit es eben gelingt sicher ist ne also
immer eine digitale Küchenwaage benutzen
wenn ich Verschleiß habe muss ich das
Nachgeben ja nachrüsten deswegen haben
wir das gezeigt wo ist unser
Schlüsselchen
hier zum Beispiel hier ist kannst du
gleich mal von der Nähe zeigen ist schon
sehr sehr grob für unser
Mandelmehl quasi und das werde ich
gleich nachrüsten dann gebe ich gleich
die Gramm Anzahl ich weiß ja nicht wie
viel es ist am Ende sind 56 Gramm werde
ich dann nachrüsten und einfach noch mal
Mandelmehl mit reingeben
[Musik]
ich mache mir heute vier verschiedene
Geschmacksrichtungen und möchte heute
auch entsprechend vier verschiedene
Farben haben daher habe ich jetzt auch
vier Schüsseln ich sag mal lieber zu
groß als zu klein daher sind das echt
schon riesige Schüsseln und ihr habt
jetzt hier wenn ihr exakt nach meinem
Rezept geht 530 Gramm von der
mandelpuderzuckermasse und davon müsst
ihr dass er dann durch vier geteilt in
die Schüssel verteilen und äh das sind
immer 132 g das wiege ich jetzt hier
daher bei diesem Rezept echt ganz
wichtig eine gut funktionierende
digitale Küchenwaage ich verlinke euch
meine mal in die Infobox genauso wie
alle anderen wichtigen Utensilien so und
da hat das war zu viel und dann geht's
auch schon weiter mit der Eiweißmasse da
gibt's aber auch ein paar Tipps und
Tricks und die verrate ich euch gleich
[Musik]
so um jetzt die Eiweißmasse
aufzuschlagen geht es ein paar Dinge zu
beachten es ist wichtig dass sowohl der
schneebesenaufsatz als auch die Schüssel
Lupen rein sauber sind keine
spülmittelreste und erst recht keine
Fettreste ganz ganz wichtig und das
mache ich jetzt auch so dass ich es mir
ab wiege weil ich will ja wie gesagt
diese vier verschiedenen Varianten will
aber nicht viel mal separat Eiweiß
aufschlagen weil es viel zu aufwendig
wäre daher nehme ich mir jetzt die Waage
wie gesagt null stellen dann wiege ich
meine Schüssel und notiere mir die zahls
2.47 Gramm so und gleich habe ich ja
dann die Schüssel mit Inhalt und dann
kann ich diesen Inhalt auch noch mal
durch vier Teilen und so habe ich dann
exakt die perfekte ja die perfekte Menge
pro Farbe quasi so wenn ihr fragen habt
übrigens schreibt es mir unbedingt in
die Kommentare ich bin immer wieder
aktiv und beantworte sie euch gerne
ansonsten hilft sich nicht untereinander
und weiter so Eiweiß gebe ich jetzt hier
in meine Schüssel in meinem alten Rezept
hatte ich euch den Tipp gegeben wenn das
Eiweiß einen Tag alt ist bzw ein Tag
lang im Kühlschrank rot ist es vom
Gefühl her besser ihr müsst es aber
nicht machen heute zum Beispiel mache
ich es auch ohne also heute habe ich das
auch nicht vorbereitet es funktioniert
trotzdem so das ganze schlage ich jetzt
auf und sobald es dann schaumig und ein
bisschen dicker wird gebe ich nach und
nach also ich lasse es wirklich ein
rieseln hier den Zucker mit dazu bis es
eine richtig schöne feste Baisermasse
ist
[Musik]
die baiser-masse ist perfekt sie ist
super aufgeschlagen das funktioniert
natürlich am einfachsten in der
Küchenmaschine muss ich sagen es geht
auch ein Handrührgerät aber dann braucht
ihr halt ein bisschen länger was er
eigentlich auch an sich kein Problem ist
so ich habe schon hier abgewogen ich
habe jetzt 245 g an Masse geteilt durch
vier sind ca 61g Eiweiß die ich jetzt
hier in meine Schüssel Tools setze ich
die Küchenwaage wieder auf 0 und nehme
dann immer ein bisschen was raus wenn
ich sehe auf der Waage schicken minus
61g dann bin ich fertig deswegen immer
pur arbeiten direkt hier immer zu den zu
der Mandel puderzuckermasse und an der
Stelle gibt dir auch schon die Farbe mit
dazu und meine Farbe gibt's auch ein
bisschen was zu beachten ihr könnt
Pulverfarben nehmen da hatte ich aber in
Vergangenheit immer das Problem dass ich
die Farbe die ich mir gewünscht habe
immer verändert hat nach dem Backen ich
nehme Lebensmittel Gel Farben die Farben
sind deshalb gut also unsere super stark
pigmentiert ihr braucht nicht viel was
im Umkehrschluss heißt es kommt nicht
viel
fremdzutat rein und verändert nicht die
Konsistenz flüssige Farben funktionieren
überhaupt nicht davon kann ich euch
schon mal komplett abraten immer ganz
kurz akribisch meine 61 Gramm so genau
da wir das jetzt hier eh Einarbeiten in
die Mandelmasse geben wir halt wie
gesagt jetzt schon mal die Lebensmittel
gfarbe dazu ich schreibe euch ganz genau
rein welche Bezeichnungen ich jeweils
genommen habe damit ihr sehen könnt wie
die Farben aussehen dann fahren Sie
immer sehr mitgenommen übertrieben oft
benutze aber ein so ein Bottich hält
halt gefühlt auch Jahre lang muss ich
sagen dann nehme ich mir einfach so ein
Zahnstocher geht da rein und dann
streife ich das einfach hier im Eiweiß
ab oder in der Mandelmasse Mandelmehl
ich sage immer Mandelmehl aber das ist
ja auch Mandelmehl nicht dass euch das
verwirrt ne das hat nichts mit diesem
normalen Mehl zu tun Typ 450 nicht sonst
so benutze also das sind wirklich nur
Mandeln so dann einfach mit dem
Teigschaber schön langsam von außen in
so streichelnden Bewegungen Arbeiten
nicht zu viel Luft rausschlagen und dann
ist die erste Masse auch schon fertig
[Musik]
also viel haben wir Angst man kann auch
selber zu machen ich muss ehrlich sagen
man braucht schon ein bisschen Übung
aber traut Euch da ruhig dran ich gebe
euch da hier ganz viele Tipps also ich
habe jetzt zum Beispiel schön gerührt
und vielleicht wird ihr denken ach ja
die Masse ist jetzt fertig aber sie
fließt noch zu langsam daher dürft ihr
ruhig noch ein paar mal mehr rühren
deswegen auch ganz wichtig die
Lebensmittelfarbe sofort mit dazu geben
weil wenn die Konsistenz gut ist aber
ihr denkt auch die Farbe können sich
jetzt eigentlich noch ein bisschen mehr
vermengen könnt ihr nicht weiterhin weil
dann lauft der hat Gefahr dass die Masse
durch das viele rühren und unterheben zu
flüssig ist und dann habt ihr zwar eine
schöne Farbe aber eure Meinung ausgelegt
nicht und was ich aber auch schön finde
muss ich sagen lass es einfach mal
passieren weil vielleicht habt ihr noch
so ein Marvel Effekt und der sieht auf
macaos auch sehr schön aus jetzt habe
ich so ganz leicht Effekt muss ich sagen
so das fließt noch ein bisschen zu
langsam aber es ist schon fast perfekt
ich habe noch so zwei drei Mal unter und
dann passt es eigentlich und ihr könnt
euch daran orientieren dass so ein
bisschen wie ein V von eurem Teigschaber
runterfließt ich muss euch das zeigen
dann könnt ihr euch das genauestens
vorstellen
so quasi ich weiß nicht ob man sieht
[Musik]
es geht so zu Spitze wie ein V runter
und dann ist es fertig und dann können
wir in den Spritzbeutel umfüllen wobei
ich jetzt erstmal noch die anderen
Farben mache und dann fülle ich komplett
um
[Musik]
so jetzt sind alle Massen fertig die
letzte habe ich weiß gelassen weil das
wird Kokos und deshalb passt der weiß
ganz gut so jetzt nehme ich mir mein
Spritzbeutel und entweder schneidet ihr
vorne die Spitze ab und habe dann ein
Loch oder ihr nehmt direkt ein Loch
Tülle es funktioniert beides mit der
Lochtülle muss ich sagen hat man einfach
ein bisschen schöneres Ergebnis weil ihr
dann vom Schneiden nicht eventuell
irgendwie so Zacken drin hat so einfach
die Tülle hier rein tun
vorne abschneiden und dann einmal
rauspressen und dann könnt ihr schon mal
den ersten Teig einfüllen und das ganze
auf euer Backblech
spritzen da gibt gebe ich euch gleich
aber auch noch ein paar Tipps
[Musik]
so jetzt kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle
diese Macarons Silikon backmatten die
sind auch okay die könnt ihr Nutzen wenn
ihr euch vielleicht super unsicher seid
aber ich kann euch nur sagen habt
einfach Spaß an der Sache es werden sich
immer zwei makerungsschalen finden die
aufeinander passen immer und daher mache
ich das jetzt erstmal nicht möchte ich
zeigen dass es auch ohne geht wenn ihr
nicht möchte dass euch das Backpapier
hin und her rutscht weil es kann schon
echt nervig sein und es sollte auch
nicht hin und her rutschen weil sonst
die ja die macaro Schalen vielleicht
auch dadurch so ein bisschen ungerade
werden können durch diese Bewegung nimmt
euch so ein bisschen von dem Teig und
sieht das hier so auf das Blech das ist
wie so eine Art Kleber und dadurch
fixiere ich das einfach von allen Seiten
so und jetzt müsst ihr nur diesen einen
Tipp beherzigen und zwar komplett
senkrecht von oben zu spritzen also
wirklich nicht schräg sondern so von
oben mit gleichmäßigen Druck auf den
Spritzbeutel und dann einfach loslassen
und dann so ein bisschen Abstand lassen
sie gehen um minimal in die Breite aber
noch mehr in die Höhe
so und dann wie gesagt wenn sich immer
zwei macauerschalen finden die
aufeinander passen
[Musik]
ah ja genau ganz ganz wichtig dass wenn
ihr Bläschen entdecken das ist ganz
normal einfach ein paar mal auf die
Arbeitsfläche Haut so dann erinnert mich
so ein bisschen einen Sand Sebastian
Cheesecake so dann kommen die Pünktchen
quasi Luftbläschen an die Oberfläche
also macht das ruhig ein paar Mal ich
will es euch euren Ohren jetzt nicht
antun ich mache das gleich noch mal und
dann nimmt euch ein Zahnstocher und
piekst die Luftbläschen so ein bisschen
kaputt dreht noch ein paar mal hier im
Kreis und dann habt ihr auch wirklich
ein wunderschönes Ergebnis
[Musik]
ich habe noch einen Tipp für euch ich
habe echt viele Tipps muss ich sagen und
zwar wenn ihr eure Spritztülle befüllt
dann knickt das so nach innen weil wenn
ihr dann so ein Gedanken seid und die
befüllt dann fließt euch ja unten alles
wieder raus aus einfach so reinknicken
und dann festhalten und dann stülpe ich
mir das hier so einfach so in die Hand
und dann kann ich ganz einfach befüllen
und dann nehme ich mir gleich noch ein
Winkelpalette da könnt ihr auch eine
Teigkarte oder sowas nehmen irgendwas
was gerade ist und jetzt nicht gerade
besser scharf ist weil sonst schneidet
euch da irgendwas an der Oberfläche
kaputt und dann schiebe ich so meinen
Teig nach vorne und dadurch vermeidet
ihr halt auch noch mal Luftbläschen bzw
diese Luft die dann im Spritzbeutel ist
und dann gibt es wie so ein Pups
rauskommt
[Musik]
so bei mir haben sie heute tatsächlich
45 Minuten gebraucht um anzutrocknen ihr
merkt es daran dass wir nicht ganz
vorsichtig dürft natürlich nicht viel
Kraft anwenden aber so ganz vorsichtig
drauf geht auf die Oberfläche da bleibt
nichts kleben dann sind Sie bereit für
den Backofen den müsst ihr unbedingt
vorheizen auf 130 Grad Umluft in meiner
alten in dieser Studentenwohnung also in
der Wohnung wo alles angefangen hat mit
YouTube da habe ich 140 Grad Umluft
genommen aber jeder Backofen ist anders
also ihr bewegt sich immer zwischen 130
und 140 Grad schaut am besten mal wie es
bei euch am besten gelingt aber startet
lieber ein bisschen niedriger also 130
ist eigentlich immer eine gute Option
und dann kommt jetzt ins untere Drittel
und wird dann so lange gebacken bis
diese Füßchen entstehen das dauert so
ungefähr 14 bis maximal 17 18 Minuten
[Musik]
so meine macaron-schalen sind jetzt alle
gebacken lasst sie unbedingt auskühlen
bevor ihr sie anhebt das ist ganz ganz
wichtig und jetzt nehme ich mir meine
pistaziencreme und befüllt erstmal die
Grünen Schalen es bietet sich halt
perfekt an die ganze cream Reihe jetzt
einfach zu benutzen was ihr auch machen
könnt ist eine Ganache z.B Marmelade
Sahne Mascarpone geht einfach alles muss
sagen jetzt wo ich die Cremes nutze sind
sie natürlich auch länger haltbar als
wenn jetzt so eine Sahne Füllung macht
und sie schmecken halt auch einfach echt
gut ne
Löffeln kann und daher schmecken sie
auch pur in Macarons so und dann einfach
mit der Schere hier vorne die Spitze
abschneiden und dann nach vorne schieben
und jetzt nehmen wir uns ein so eine
Schale und natürlich müsst ihr darauf
achten dass die von der Größe her auch
einander passen
aber da habe ich ja gerade gesagt ihr
findet immer ein Pärchen so und jetzt
einfach in die Mitte die pistaziencreme
geben so und das tolle ist dass ihr dann
nichts erwärmen müsst manchmal ist es ja
so dann sage ich legt sie in die
Mikrowelle dass die ein bisschen weicher
wird aber das hat die perfekte
Konsistenz guckt und wenn ihr das jetzt
in den Kühlschrank tut dann wird die
Creme auch noch mal richtig schön
bissfest
[Musik]
strawberry Queen da könnte man gleich
eigentlich
Yogurette eigentlich so ein Stückchen
mit dazu tun weil sie schmeckt wirklich
wie Yogurette nur aufs Brot deswegen
durfte die jetzt bei mir auch nicht
fehlen und der Klassiker ist jetzt hier
natürlich unsere Hazel cream der große
Bruder der allererstes kam und da werde
ich jetzt diese braun gefärbten Schalen
befüllen und ganz zum Schluss kommt noch
Kokos also quasi flüssig geworden ist
Raffaello das schmeckt wirklich wie die
Füllung von Raffaello schreibt mir gerne
mal in die Kommentare welche creams ihr
schon zu Hause habt und welche euer
Favorit ist Leute übrigens Vorsicht beim
Anheben denn guck mal diesen sehr
zerbrechlich
[Musik]
also ich finde Macarons müssen nicht nur
hübsch aussehen sondern auf jeden Fall
auch schmecken und ich weiß es mal rein
für euch
lecker
das ist einfach Yogurette ne nicht
offiziell Yogurette Macarons also wenn
ich euch jetzt motiviert habe auch
Macarons zu machen dann schicken eure
Fotos bzw markiert mich auf Instagram
und ähm ja macht auf jeden Fall fleißig
nach es ist wirklich einfacher als man
denkt und ich habe euch so viele Tipps
gegeben ich weiß gar nicht wie viel ist
weil ich habe gar nicht mitgezählt aber
es ist unfassbar viele Tipps in diesem
Video und ich hoffe dass es euch
gefallen hat und freue mich wenn ihr
meinen Kanal kostenlos abonniert und
wenn ihr mögt schreibt mir noch mal in
die Kommentare welches Rezept jetzt als
nächstes backschule sehen möchtet
sondern nächster Tag also ich habe mir
gedacht so du musst den test test machen
ich hätte dir das auch einfach zum
Online-Shop gebracht weil wir gestern
nicht dabei aber jetzt bist du hier und
sie schmecken ja auch tagelang gemacht
sie echt vier bis fünf Tage nur immer in
den Kühlschrank tun ja zu den in so eine
Frischhaltedose Deckel drauf und dann
halten
ja dann schmecken sie zwar fleißig mal
ganz so frisch aber ist ja auch eine
Option und jetzt soll ich mir jetzt
aussuchen ja verschiedene
Geschmacksrichtungen Haselnuss
deswegen
zu Hause
das ist noch nie so gescheitert mich
angeguckt habe
ich muss sagen
es gibt voll allein letzten Monat danke
dafür auch machen makarus und gefunden
mit unseren creams ey finde ich auch
immer sehr sehr süß mega
es passt wirklich perfekt und die
Schalen sind ein bisschen aufwendiger
dafür ist die Creme direkt bereit für
die Füllung das macht wieder gut
ja deswegen hast du den zum Schluss
aufgehoben
boah
ohne Spaß ich musste noch eine Varianten
machen
Schale und die Creme echt geil 10%
eines Videos ich bin froh dass ich dich
geheiratet habe
wenn Sie bei uns im Café geben würde
zum Kaffee geben will
ja wieso kommt doch ein bisschen bald
vielleicht
naja auf jeden Fall danke
bis zum nächsten mal auf meinem Kanal
tschüss testen lassen welche Macarons
besser schmecken Kikis oder Supermarkt
also man merkt auf jeden Fall ein sehr
sehr großen Unterschied also die von
Kiki sie sind viel Softair und weicher
und die da laufen so viel besser auch
auf der Zunge als die Rating 10
die sind anders auf dem Teich dicker
aber würden sie nennt man denn essen
ich würde definitiv die nehmen weil die
optisch sehr schön sind die gucken mich
schon an wir sind größer frische
fluffiger
süß
[Musik]